hi thank you for being here today
i'll be talking about the role of rna
scope
in spatial mapping of gene expression in
tumors
for those of you who are not familiar
with our technology rna scope is an nc2
hybridization technique
that was specifically designed to
overcome some of the traditional
limitations
of an ish assay while still providing
very high
specificity and sensitivity of detection
the rna scope technology is the perfect
solution
for spatial analysis of your target gene
expression
it can help interrogate complex tissues
like the tumor
where you have different cell types with
varying degree of gene expression
the three major parts of our technology
are the target probe design
the signal amplification strategy and
the detection
and quantification system because of our
unique
probe design and amplification strategy
it is the perfect solution
for analyzing rna biomarkers and
potential therapeutic targets
act will design a specific target probe
against the gene of your interest
a unique signal amplification strategy
ensures
very high signal to noise ratio and our
detection and quantification system
allows for visualization of a single
molecule of rna
at string cell resolution our assay can
be applied for detection of mrna
long non-coding rnas slice variants
highly homologous sequences short
targets
and point mutations and our assay can be
can be applied in ssda tissues fresh and
fixed-frozen tissues
pbmcs or cultural cells so this
gives researchers ample flexibility to
use this technology
in different sample types and for
detection of different targets
in this next slide i'm going to go in a
little bit more detail
to talk about our probe design strategy
and the signal amplification system the
two key features of this technology
that make it stand apart from some of
the techniques that are out there
as you can see on your screen i have
depicted the rna scope probe
as a z molecule and this is mainly
to highlight the three different regions
of the probe
the pre-amplifier binding site the
linker region
and the target binding site as the name
suggests
the target binding site is the area of
the probe that will bind on to your
target sequence
when we design the probe we desir we
design it
such that two z probes have to bind
in tandem next to each other on your
target sequence now this
forms the foundation of the preamplifier
binding site
to which pre-amplifier molecule comes
and binds to the repair
followed by this there is the binding of
amplifier and then you have your label
probes
binding on to the amplifiers this
signal detection strategy allows for
very high
sensitivity and we can detect even the
most
low expressing targets now as i
mentioned previously
for the preamplifier to bind on to the
rna scope probe
the 2 z molecules or probes have to be
bind
have to be bound in tandem if a z probe
binds not specifically
to another mrna molecule then the
preamplifier will not bind to a single z
probe
and there won't be any amplification t4
as a result no signal will be detected
now this ensures
very high specificity of protection
giving you a high signal to noise ratio
in addition to our rna scope assays we
also have this
they call the periscope assay which is
specifically used
for detection of targets that are short
between 50
to 300 nucleotides in length now these
include
your exon junctions point mutations
highly homologous sequences
etc the product design strategy between
our rna scope and base scope assays
also varies uh to some extent
for our rna scope assays we design a
pooled probe of 20 zz pairs
and for our base scope assays we have a
pulled probe
of one to three z repairs mainly because
we are targeting a shorter sequence
in this slide uh i have elaborated the
breadth
of our product portfolio uh we
offer assays that can allow single flex
detection
duplex detection and up to 12 flex of
target detection
for rna scope where you can visualize 12
targets
simultaneously for our base scope assay
currently
we can detect up to two targets
simultaneously
we offer both the rna scope and base
scope assays
in a manual platform and an automated
platform
currently we have over 26 000 target
probes in our catalog
but if you're interested in a probe or a
target chain that is not currently in
our catalog
we can design a custom probe in less
than two weeks
we are very excited to announce that in
the next couple of months
we will be launching our micro rna scope
assay
which is specifically designed to detect
muscle rnase
and asos and srnas
now because of the flexibility of our
assay
we are able to use rna scope
for for multitude of applications
and in different research areas as you
can see on your screen
this technology has been used for
detection of long non-coding
rna cdr3 regions on pcrs
gprs soil mutations for validation
of high super data and so on
and because of this it has been used in
basic science research
for neuroscience and developmental
biology
in infectious disease research for
understanding emerging pathogens
and study inflammation induced by
infection
for biopharma discovery and development
research
uh in cell and gene therapy analysis to
assess the pre-clinical safety
and efficacy of these therapies
and finally for cancer clinical research
wherein it has been used extensively in
understanding the tumor biology
and studying uh different immune cell
markers in immune oncology
for the purpose of today's presentation
i'll be focusing
on the applications of rna scope in
oncology and immuno oncology
in this slide i have summarized the
different applications of how
rna scope and base scope assays have
been used
in cancer research they have been used
to visualize tumor heterogeneity
study the varying degree of expression
of a specific target
in different parts of the tumor to
characterize a new cell conceivable
factor
visualize specific subpopulation of
immune cells
and study the expression of cytokines
and chemokines within those cells
then to specifically detect tcr
to identify specific cdr3 regions and
identify clonal t cells
to detect splice variants which can be
pretty significant
in cancer research as certain spice
variants are
known to promote cancer growth and
metastasis next is to identify
non-coding rnas
again an important family of regulatory
rnas
that are non-coding but can influence
cancer growth and progression to
spatially map
sequencing data which includes
validation of high stupid data like
single cell rna sequencing
and visualizing and validating those
data
in a morphological context and finally
to detect
engineered immune cells such as car t
cell therapies
let's start with the first application
which is to visualize
tumor heterogeneity
in this particular example we have used
the rna scope assay
to visualize pdl1 mrna in lung cancer
tumors
on your screen you can see four
different panels depicting
expression of pdl1 in four different
lung cancer tumors
and you can appreciate the difference in
the degree of expression
of pdl1 in these tumors although they
are the same type of tumor
the expression of pdr1 varies
significantly
between these four samples highlighting
the heterogeneous expression of pdl1
in lung cancer tumors
in this next image we have shown the
expression
of pdl-1 in this same tumor
in different parts of the same tumor
where you can see that pdl1 is expressed
at a much higher degree in the top right
corner
compared to the bottom left corner
showing that cdl1 not only
exhibits inter-tumor heterogeneity but
also shows intra-tumor retrogenerating
where its expression can vary depending
on
the specific meat within the tumor
and this can be extremely significant
for targets like pdl-1
pdl-1 or ctla-4 which are important
targets for immunotherapies
next i want to show you an example of
how
we were able to compare the differential
expression of some of these immune
targets
between two lung cancer tumors from our
tma core of lung tumors
we are focusing on core number two e2
and comparing it
to core number two f1 as you can see on
the screen
we have used our duplex assay to
visualize
different immune checkpoint markers
including pd1
pdl1 pdl2 black 3
tim 3 and ctla-4 it is very obvious that
the expression of
all of these immune checkpoint markers
is significantly higher in the code to
e2
compared to the two core to f1
and this is also evident from the
quantification
detailed in the table below
when we compare the expression of immune
cell markers within these two cores
we see that the 2e2 core also called as
the hot core
uh shows a much higher degree of
expression
of these immune cell markers compared to
2 f1
the markers estrogens specifically
include
markers like endocrine gamma and cd8
which
are markers for cytotoxic lymphocytes
fox t3 cb4 which are markers for
regulatory t
cells cxcl10 cd68
for m1 macrophages and ccl22
cd163 as markers for m2 macrophages
and it is clearly visible that the
degree of infiltration of these immune
cells
is much higher in the hot core compared
to the cold core
potentially suggesting that a patient
with the 2e2 tumor
was more likely to have a successful
immunotherapeutic response compared to
the patient
in the 2f1 core
so using these uh this technique we were
able to visualize
the immune cell infiltration between two
different tumor types
and understand potential response to
therapy
looking at these markers and ironing
scope also helps
identify the cellular source of these
secreted cytokines
and chemokines here's an example of how
researchers have used
the rna scope assay to visualize the
heterogeneity
of vent ligand expression in these
pancreatic tumors
they have developed a pancreatic tumor
organoid library
and then studied the expression of vint
ligands
within these tumors to understand the
dependency
of these tumors on the wind signaling
pathway
and what they observed was compared to
the normal pancreas
the w0 negative tumors or the tumors
that were went not secreting
expressed significantly lower levels of
these three went ligands compared to the
w
positive or vent secreting a
tumor organized seen in the rightmost
column of this panel
so using this technology they were able
to
understand uh the expression signature
of winged ligands within these different
pancreatic tumors
and study the dependency of these tumors
on the wind signaling pathway
giving them novel insights on the
tumorogenesis
of pancreatic cancer
now we are going to move on to the next
application of rna scope
which is to use rna scope to
characterize
immune cells and study soluble factors
one of the most important workflows of
using rna scope is its ability to
combine rna scope with immunistic
chemistry or immunofluorescence
because of the natural complementarity
of these two technologies
we can use that in combination and
visualize
rna and protein simultaneously on the
same section
now this becomes extremely important in
immuno oncology
wherein you can use specific antibodies
to mark certain immune cells and then
study the gene expression
using rna scope within those specific
populations of immune cells
and here is an example of how we've
utilized this joint
ish ic workflow in this cervical cancer
we use the cd3 antibody
to mark all the t cells and then study
the expression
of pdl1 pd1 and interferon gamma
using rna scope so combining our
multiplex assay with
immunofluorescence we were able to
identify a specific cell type
and then study gene expression within
those cells
using rna scope you were able to
highlight the cells
that were expressing high degrees of
interferon gamma
potentially identifying the active t
cells
within the cervical cancer tumor
microenvironment
and this particular image also uh lets
you appreciate
the single molecule and single cell
resolution that you can get with rna
scope
a single punctate doctor refers to a
single transcript or molecule of
rna and you can visualize these at the
single cell resolution
this joint workflow of using rle scope
with isc or is
um is not only limited to the
fluorescent platform
but can be done on the chromogenic
platform as well
in this example we have visualized cd68
cxel9 and il-12 in the lung cancer
tumors
using the cd68 antibody we have
potentially marked all the macrophages
and then studied the expression of il-12
and cxcl9 which are both soluble factors
using rna scope so this allows us
to pinpoint or identify the cells that
are secreting
these soluble factors within this lung
cancer tumor
a similar example of using cd4 antibody
in combination with tgf beta and fox p3
probe
and here you can nicely see how we have
been able to visualize
the cd4 positive t cells in the stroma
of this lung cancer tumor
and then co-localize the expression of
tgf beta
and fox p3 to these cells and
so this tells you that using rna scope
you can study gene expression in
different compartments
of the tumor
now this is an example of how
researchers have used
this dual ish isd or dualish if workflow
for their research this paper published
in nature
last year utilized the rna scope duplex
and multiplex assays
to study the effect of lyf or
leukemia inhibitory factor in promoting
pancreatic cancer growth
as you can see here we have compared the
expression of
um lith and keratin 19 between normal
and cancer tumors
and you can see that keratin 19 has been
used to mark the tumor cell
and lip is expressed predominantly
in the stroma suggesting that lip is not
expressed by the tumor cells
but by a population of cells called the
pancreatic cellulic cells
which are present in the stroma and are
secreting lift
so any potential effect that lift has on
the cancer cells
is a parasite effect and not an
autocrine effect
they further went on to show that when
they collocalized
lift ptprc with keratin 19 antibody
they were again able to demark the tumor
cells and then
show co-localization of lip with ptprc
which is
cd45 emphasizing that lift was
expressed in the stroma and not in the
tumor cells
they also went on to show that less ah
is definitely a fact of promoting
pancreatic growth in this particular
study
because they saw that calculating levels
of lip
were significantly higher in cancer
patients compared to normal samples
similarly they showed that there was a
strong correlation
between lift mrna and decreased disease
free survival
one of the next applications i want to
talk to you about is a very exciting
application
which is using base scope assays to
detect
cdi3 regions on tcrs
in the last decade or so there has been
a lot of emphasis
on um engineered t cell therapies
and to do this it's important to
identify
specific clonal populations of t cells
and using our base scope assay we can
design
a specific probe against the cdr3
lesions of tcr
and identify clonal populations of t
cells
because these are highly really short
hypervariable regions
it can be very challenging to detect
these uh
with a morphological context so our base
scope as they be
a specialized essay for short targets we
are able to
specifically design proofs against these
cdr3 regions
and identify clonal populations of t
cells
now here is an example where we design
cdr3 probes
against the alpha alpha chain of gercat
cdr3 and then cgrc alpha
and beta of ccrs
so when we looked at the expression of
these
serial trees in the particular cell line
you are only able to detect positive
signal
in that particular cell line
highlighting the specificity
of our base scope cdrc probes in
detecting target of
interest and this was again nicely
demonstrated
in this paper uh in nature medicine
from dr balco's lab vanderbilt where
they were treating a patient
with anti-pd1 therapy and the patient uh
was responding well to the therapy
initially but later
showed adverse event to this therapy
which caused encephalitis
which was ultimately fatal they wanted
to understand what kind of immune
response was induced by this therapy
that led to encephalitis so upon doing
pcr frequency of this tissue they were
able to identify a specific sequence
uh that was predominantly expressed in
this tissue they designed the base scope
probe against the sequence
and when they colloquialized this uh
with either cd4
or cd8 antibody they were able to see
that this
tcr sequence co-localized with cd4
positive
t cells uh and not with cd8 positive t
cells
thus showing that this population of t
cells that induced enzyme like this
was a cd4 positive c star population
upon further analysis they were able to
identify that it was indeed
a cd4 positive memory t-cell population
that was causing this encephalitis and
using the base copassay
they were actually able to visualize
this population of t
cells within this encephalitis tissue
here's another example of how rna scope
was used to study t cells in this case
these researchers
were studying the gamma delta t cells
and their role in potentiating tumor
growth
now gamma density cells are ideally
known
uh to act against tumor growth infection
and tissue damage but with age
the effect of the with age the
role of gamete t cells in preventing
tumor growth
uh is altered and what these researchers
are trying to show
is that compared to younger mice in the
age demise
you see that the guy middle t cells
to increase expression of inhibitory
cytokines like ir7 and ir17
which in turn potentiate tumor growth
so again uh using our multiplex acid we
were able to visualize
the soluble factors like il-7 in
combination
with tcr's specific to gamma delta t
cells
next i want to talk to you about another
very exciting application
of the rna scope technology which is to
identify and detect engineered immune
cells
so in the last decade or so there have
been a lot of research
around developing car t cells for
specific antigens
in solid tumors this is a study in
collaboration with bluebird bio
where they were trying to develop cardi
cells against bcma
and rawan antigen and using the rna
scope technology
we were able to design a specific probe
that
was designed against the three prime utr
of the car vector
that went into these car t cells
in addition we were also able to
visualize
markers like granodine d interferon
gamma
which are markers for active t cells or
engaged t cells
so for the anti-dcma therapy
when they designed these scar t cells
and injected them in the pre-clinical
mouse model
they looked at the expression of these
car t cells in different tissues
here if you're looking at the expression
of the bcme antigen
and the car t cells in the mouse plane
on your right hand side panel you can
see that the spleen tissue of this mouse
has no
bcme antigen expression and on your left
hand side
you can see in red the car t cells that
are present in the screen
but you do not see any green signal
which would be indicative of positive
granuline b
expression so in this normal mouse plane
although the car t cells are present
they are not engaged
because there is no bc any antigen
present
on the other hand when we are looking at
the xenograph tumor
of this preclinical mouse model the
tumor now has the bcme antigen present
and the scar t cells are not only
expressed
in this particular tumor but they're
also showing
engagement indicated by strong
expression of gramazine b
signal so this shows you that in the
presence of the specific antigen
the car t cells are able to engage and
uh detect the antigen so this shows you
that this
anti-bcna cardiac cell therapy was
effective
and specific and was not showing any
on target of tumor effects
on the other hand when they looked at
the efficacy of the anti-rod one card
therapy
uh the result was something different
they were seeing a lot of toxicity
uh in the mouse lung and they were
trying to identify the reason
behind this toxicity when they used isc
to identify the expression of raw one
they saw
that they were not able to pick up any
raw one signal
in the lung tissue but they were still
getting this pulmonary toxicity
because of quality therapy but when they
used rna scope to visualize raw
one expression as you can see there is
very low but some basal level of norman
expression
in this lung tissue as a result of which
these car t cells were not only present
but now engaging within the lung causing
pulmonary toxicity in this particular
preclinical model
and they showed them that the raw one uh
karthi therapy
had off tumor on target but of tumor
effects
which can be potentially toxic
similar to lung they also observe
hepatic toxicity
but when they actually looked at the
expression of raw one antigen
and car t cells in the xero graft tumor
they found that
for some reason these car t cells were
now
not present at that higher degree in the
xenograph
and were not engaging either potentially
because they were exhausted
so ultimately they deduced that
the anti-bcna card therapy was
successful was
uh effective and did not throw any
non-specific effects
whereas the antidote one carti therapy
showed some on target
of tumor effects and was therefore
potentially uh
toxic
and here is just an example of how using
the multiplex assay
in the bcma antibcme model we were able
to now visualize
the car t cells indicated in green
all t cells indicated in seed by in
white
by cv3 antibody engaged t
cells indicated in red by gram design
signal
and expression of interferon gamma
indicated in pink
so we were able to distinguish between
car t and endogenous t cells
and then visualize which t cells were
engaging
next i want to talk to you about a very
popular application
of the rna scope and base scope
technology which is to
spatially map and seque especially map
sequencing data as the new cell
resolution
in the last few years a single cell rna
sequencing
has gained a lot of importance and this
is because it is a technique
that allows visualization of gene
expression at the single
cell level and they although you don't
get the morphological context
you get information of each and every
cell within the tube
within the tissue and this allows you to
study the different cell populations
within the tissue
and understand their specific function
but
what you lack is the morphological
and spatial context that you get by rna
scope
so a lot of the times researchers will
do the single cell sequencing
analysis and then come back to rna scope
to
validate and visualize their data and
spatially map
using a morphological context
so here's an example that was published
last year
from harvard and mit collaboration
where they analyzed glioblastoma tumors
using single-cell ionic sequencing
and identified four different cellular
states in which glioblastoma cells exist
now these distant cellular states were
also characterized by
expression of specific molecular markers
what they wanted to do was visualize
these different molecular
molecular and cellular septites in situ
and they use the rna-scope duplex assay
to pick specific markers pertaining to
each and individual cellular state
and visualize these cells uh within the
tissue
but what they discovered was the
glioblastoma cells can not only exist as
a specific cellular state
but they can exist in a hybrid state
where they exhibit characteristics of
more than one cellular state
and they observe this by showing
co-localization
of markers specific to different
cellular states in the same cell
using rna scope so using our technology
they were able to visualize
this hybrid state of tumor cells in
global stoma
which can potentially add to our
understanding
of how this tumor works and how this
tumor progresses
to help identify better therapeutic
strategies to treat this deadly
malignancy
similar to the example uh in the
previous slide
uh the same group of researchers also
published another paper
where they did single sequence single
cell analysis on nadiloblastoma tumors
and identified a different phenotypic
subtype
of medulloblastoma cells
based on their uh wind signature
and they categorize these as four
different wind molecular subgroups
are using the base scope assay they were
able to visualize these different sub
groups
by uh co-localizing the markers
within the tumor tissue
here's another example where these
researchers
characterize cancer associated
fibroblasts in this breast cancer tissue
using single cell sequencing analysis
they were able to identify four
different populations of gas
and using rna scope they were able to
visualize
these different populations within the
tumor tissue
and validate their single cell rna
sequencing data
so next i want to uh dive deeper into
studying how the base scope assay can
help
advance your oncology research a
detection of size variants can be very
tricky
because these are products of the same
gene and can structurally be pretty
similar
although can have different functions so
detecting spice variants at the protein
level
can often be challenging but using a
specific base coprobe
we can distinguish between the different
slice variants
of a single g now here's an example of
how
these researchers use the base scope
assay to identify the delta 16 her2
slice variant
in breast cancer and other tumors so the
pro design strategy that they employed
was they designed the probe
that spanned exon 15 and exon 17 of the
whole
2 transcript this could allow
for detection of only the transcript
that had
exon 16 missing that way they could
detect the delta 16 slice variant
they also designed probe that spanned
exon 15 and exon 16
that would now detect the wild eye
culture
and then a third probe that would span
exon 17 and exon 18
which would detect both the wild type
and the slice variant
and they use these three probes to study
the expression of the whole two
receptor in breast cancer colorectal
cancer
to end gastric cancer tumors
so here they saw that uh in these
samples
that are that are mentioned on the
screen
they were able to see the expression of
the delta 16 whole 2 stripes variant
the y type 42 as well as
they saw positive signals for the probe
to expand both
the splice variant and the y type 42 but
with
the her2 antibody they were not able to
distinguish
between these different size variants
and wild types
so they used the base scope assay to
stratify
patients for uh herceptin therapy
because patients that have the delta
sixty homeospice variant
respond really well to herceptin
treatment
and using that base scope assay they
were able to identify patients
who would respond better to this therapy
and stratify other patients
who would not benefit from this
particular treatment
so the specificity of our assay
allows for specific detection
of price variants that are significant
in promoting
tumor growth like the delta 16 price
variant
now here's an example uh where the
researchers
use the base scope assay to look at the
circular slice variant
of androgen receptor and its role
in prostate cancer progression
the circular form of this androgen
receptor is known to be associated
with progression and metastasis of
prostate cancer
on the slide you can see the comparison
between
the expression of this circ ar
splice variant of androgen receptor
between
hormone naive and castration resistant
tumors
in this particular example you can see
that the expression
of the circular rna is significantly
higher
in the castration resistant tumor
compared to the hormone knife tumors
indicating that these tumors that are
more resistant
to any therapeutic intervention
are showing increased expression of the
spice variant
potentially suggesting that it might
have a role
in driving the growth and progression
of this tumor so this indicates that our
basico as they can not only be used
for detection of linear rna but can also
be used for detection
of circular rna splice variants
another application of the rna scope
technology that is less common
is detection of long non-coding rnas but
these can be extremely significant when
it comes to oncology
long-range coding rnas can contribute to
the initiation and progression
of several malignancies since they don't
have
any protein products detecting relevant
long non-coding rnas
has been quite challenging using
specific target
probes we can identify long non-coding
rnas in
any tissue and any tumors
here's an example of how researchers
have used
rna scope to visualize a newly
identified
long non-coding rna called nuclear
leucas
within the nucleus of these lung cancer
cells
they established that this nuclear-long
non-coding irony
was upregulated under hypoxic conditions
and promoted an aggressive phenotype
within the lung cancer tumors
another group used the rna-scope
technology
to demonstrate the upregulation of the
long non-coding rnas
in metastatic breast cancer about 90
percent
of the brain mess were positive for this
particular
target what i would like you to
appreciate here in the first example
is the cellular resolution that you can
get
with rna scope if you have a
really good microscope you can call here
we have co-localized
nucleic nuclear rna with meat one
nuclear long-run calling rna
using our multiplex fluorescent assay so
you can visualize both these targets
within the nucleus in addition
to both these examples we have a lot
more publications that have used rna
scope to visualize
the long encoding rnas of interest in
cancer cells and tissues
this is another example of how
we can use different probes to identify
long encoding rnas
that are significant in a particular
malignancy
here you can use four different probes
in four different tumors
and you can appreciate the different uh
pattern of expression of
each of these long non-coding rnas where
we're in the gas 5-long non-coding rnas
expressed in breast cancer
shows both nuclear and cytoplasmic
expression
whereas the mallet one long non-coding
rna
shows specifically nuclear expression in
this lung cancer tumor
so with our technology you can get that
subcellular localization
of targets like these long encoding rnas
which can be significant in
understanding their function
in tumor growth and progression
so i want to take the remainder of the
time to talk about
a very exciting um collaboration
between acd biotechnic and nanostring
technology
where we have combined our technologies
in a single workflow
to give you highly plexed spatial
analysis with morphological context
early scope is now a part of the geomax
dsp workflow where rna scope can be used
as a molecular
guide to direct the dsp uh the geomex
csp
on specific areas of the tumor which can
then be profiled
using the dsp quantified using the
encounter
and then targets of interest can be
validated using
rna scope on ethereal section
so this is a workflow which we believe
can help
address several questions for immuno
oncology research
and this is especially significant for
samples
with high heterogeneity
we wanted to show that this particular
workflow
can be made applicable for an actual
uh study within a lung cancer tumor
sample
so we've decided to investigate the new
cell infiltration and the expression of
associated cytokines
in the tumor microenvironment
so the first step is to identify regions
of interest
using specific early scope probes the
second step as i mentioned is to perform
the digital spatial profiling using the
geomets
on these identified regions of interest
and then the third step is to validate
or confirm the data
that you get from your geomix dsp again
with that
single cell and single uh molecule
resolution
with rna scope so to show the
applicability of this technology
uh we decided to use
the cd3 and cd19 rna scope probes
to interrogate this lung cancer tumor
sample
and thought that different regions of
this lung cancer tumor
had varying degree of cd19 and cd3
expression
some regions had higher degree of cd19
expression
or some regions in high degree of cd3
expression
and this indicates the differential
expression
or differential levels of immune cell
infiltration
within this lung cancer tumor
so the 24 regions of entrance that were
identified
were a mix of high pd3 high
and moderate expression of both targets
after identifying these 24 regions of
interest
they were then analyzed using the
geomets dsp
the geometry panel that we chose is the
i o panel
which consists of 78 immuno oncology
related targets
and what we saw was that there was a
significant differential
expression between the genes that were
um analyzed between cd19 rich rois
and compared to cd3 rich rois
wherein the targets that were up
regulated in the cd19 which rois
were mainly antigen presenting cell
targets targets like a cd40
cd74 whereas the targets that were
upregulated and enriched in the cd3 rich
regions of interest were mainly t-cell
markers
and chemokines and cytokines now
our cd19 rich regions we expect
are regions that are high in b cells and
cd3 raised regions
are regions that we expect are high in t
cells
so after having analyzed this by digital
spatial profiling
our next step was to validate these
some of the key targets that we analyzed
using rna scope on a serial section
so for that purpose uh we selected roi
6 and roi 11. as you can see roi 6 is
a cd19 rich roi and roi 11 is a cd3 rich
roi
so this way we can compare the
differential gene expression
between these two roi that we got from
our geomets dsp analysis
and then pick certain key targets that
would essentially express
and come back to rna scope to validate
that expression
on a serial section
so the key targets that we pick for
validation
are are targets like cd8 interferon
gamma
cxcl9 and ccl5 which are key
players in the cancer immunity cycle um
and these were differentially expressed
between roi 6 and roi 11.
so using our multiplex
v2 assay we were able to visualize these
targets and compare their expression
between
the cd3 rich roi and the cd19 rich roi
now as you can see in this image uh the
expression of
all of these targets was significantly
higher in the roi 11
compared to roi 6. now roi 11
is the roi that is cd3 rich
or c cell rich and cd and roi
6 is the roi which is cd19 rich or a b
cell rich so it was no surprise that
these targets
which are mainly expressed on t cells
were
expressed at a much higher level in roi
11
compared to roi 6. and it was nice to
see
that our expression pattern uh
was concordant with the dsp data that
you can see in this graph
showing that these two technologies are
comparable and their expression patterns
correlate
with one another with rna scope as i
mentioned earlier you can get that
single molecule and single cell
resolution
so after having identified your key
targets from your dsp data
you can come back and visualize your p
target expression
with morphological and tissue context
so with this joint workflow we really
wanted to address all the questions
in spatial genomics where we've used rna
score
as a molecular guide to identify key
regions
within a heterogeneous tumor then using
the geomets psp panel
we can profile these selected regions of
interest
for target gene expression
in this case targets related to io
and then visualize the key targets that
are
differentially expressed using rna scope
on a serial section
so this way we we're hoping to provide a
complete solution
for spatial genomics combining the
strength of both these technologies
to provide highly flex spatial profiling
with single cell and morphological
resolution
our technology has been widely applied
over the last few years
as you can see we have over 2700
publications
as of last month and we have been used
in various different research areas
but cancer and neuroscience are top
research areas
for publication
in addition to our broad applications in
cancer and neuroscience
we've also widely been applied in
infectious disease research
and in the current environment it's
imperative that we
expedite our research for covert 19
and help identify therapeutic and
vaccine strategies
that will help control this pandemic and
we are trying to contribute to this
by having probes uh for covet 19 that
would specifically identify
this virus and also have probes that
would identify the whole cell receptor
or chemokines cytokines immune cells and
finally
pathological and physiological markers
to study
tissue homeostasis to learn more do not
hesitate
to reach out to our support finally we
have a lot of material
related to oncology and immuno oncology
as you can see on the screen we have
white papers and app nodes
and we are also going to be presenting
four different posters
at the aacr meeting later this month so
please reach out to us with any
questions
uh you can reach out to either of the
email addresses and in the current
environment we know a lot of you cannot
get to your lab
but you still have research and grand
deadlines to meet
so at acd we have a dedicated group of
researchers
who are safely working in our office
to help advance your research we have
pharma assay services
and academic assay services for pharma
and academic customers
where you only have to send your samples
to us
we'll do the early scope analysis for
you do the data analysis
quantification and give the data back to
you
uh in four weeks so if you want to learn
more about these services that we offer
do reach out to us and contact our
support
thank you